du carlier adore les chansons d'ailleurs
nakamura ça pourrait bah oui on
rencontre de larges comme on dit d'un
carpe et du lapin
une bombe à rumeurs évidemment
totalement voilà ce qu'il a déclaré
après vous savez bien sur ce qui s'est
passé au téléthon si voulez on va
d'abord regarder la vidéo du téléthon
l'a beaucoup vu
mais quand même ça ça mérite qu'on la
revoie parce que c'est un message que
vous pourriez peut-être passé à ceux qui
vous aiment et qui vous suivent au 36 37
chaque jour je reçois beaucoup d'amour
beaucoup de soutien et je pense que je
vous remercie pas assez c'est super
important vous ne voyez pas forcément
tous les jours mais ça me booste
voilà merci encore et pour le téléthon
si vous avez message à passer à vos fans
pour qu'ils soutiennent les téléthons
byetta appeler le 36 37 pour aider la
recherche est stoppée stopper non il
faut arrêter les maladies à les faire
douter les gens voilà donc je vous
invite à à près de 6 37 voilà juste pour
vous dire j'ai adoré la réaction de
denain guiche pour hier guy car nous
voilà à l'éliminatoire en mettant génial
nagui dans sa façon de contenir son
indignation et dire d'une voix
terriblement ironique et sinon pour le
téléthon un mot c'est marca d un mois
après que cette dame tel tellement
vulgaire et arriviste a fait une promo
éhontée tandis qu'on voyait un plan de
coupe les petits myopathe bon c'est du
quartier dans le texte est ce qu'on en
sait un peu plus sur ce qui s'est passé
vraiment là bas est ce que voilà donc
dans les coulisses et tout ça ne m'est
rien dès le départ de toute façon
c'était c'était foutu parce que moi je
n'arrête pas dire qu'elle ait dit va
mais on en a la preuve aujourd'hui elle
est arrivée en retard ce qui a eu le don
de mettre en rogne déjà les équipes du
téléthon donc ça voilà et ensuite elle a
fait une petite vidéo pour rattraper un
petit peu le coup parce qu'elle a été
complètement ridicule donc pour dire son
manager est venu la voir et lui a dit il
faut absolument la thur rattrape le coup
et que tu passes et que tu passes le
message pour que tu essaies tu es fan
vote pour le fabienne payer pour leur
donne de l'argent pour le téléthon non
mais attends jusqu'à présent on
n'arrêtait pas dire qu'elle était
vivante on est pris plein la tronche et
moi la première maintenant on sait
qu'elle est débile aussi
s'agirait pas la police l'a alors j'ai
tant les mêmes infos alors oui oh que
c'est faute et a purgé pas les mêmes
infos j'ai des amis qui me je revends
ils m'ont dit pas dire qu'ils s'étaient
mais qui était donc au téléthon et elle
a été très gentille elle s'est très bien
comporté après elle a fait une petite
vidéo pour dire donner au 36 37
comme tout le monde qu'elle est pas si
tu as les allées où elle est forte comme
tout le monde ça s'est très bien passé
elle a pas vraiment compris elle a 24
noms donne la parole aux autres aussi
parce qu'ils ont peur
catherine et mathieu c'est typiquement
la fille égocentrique et en plus ça a
été mal préparée par le manager qui
pressent allons l'accompagner comme il
accompagne tous les artistes
elle arrive elle t elle sait pas où il
était elle connaissait pas les ce qu'il
fallait dire
elle crée c'est même pas le numéro donc
c'est une fille qui vit et qui est
surprotégé qui s'intéresse à rien
d'autre qu'à elle même et surtout il ya
une faute l'encadrement qui a passé une
après fait avant l'arrivée des missions
essentielles ce qu'elle soit là ces
quatre là et qu'elles sont gratuites
mois pour que son public regarde voilà
d'aller l'accabler maman elle est venu
gratuitement chanter qu'est ce que vous
les quatre faces de plus en mai après lé
pa prix nobel on savait et c'est pas
très important toute façon vous évoquez
un jour tu hésites pas oui mais tu es ya
d'autres chanteurs et de chanteuses qui
ne sont pas non plus des prix nobel mais
qui ont entendu parler du téléthon qui
est l'émission qui existe depuis 30 ans
une amie m'a choqué ce qui m'a choqué ce
matin sa bêtise tous ces bêtes en fait
elle a fait ses bêtes bon c'est que j'ai
vu qu'elle a été défendue sur les
réseaux sociaux par des producteurs de
grandes émissions qu'on commençait à
dire que les gens qui la critiquaient
étaient des aigris des lakers
départ 10 h déjeuner mar une loi que
quand je mets un navigateur
dès qu'on a une émane avis différent se
fait traiter des grilles ou détachement
ça suffit il ya un moment dans la vie
normale
non madame eh ben voilà moi ce que je
remets oui je trouve ce que je trouve
vraiment absurde de nos jours c'est
comme maintenant on se fait défoncer
mais sur les réseaux sociaux là la
preuve elle s'est fait littéralement bah
voilà de toutes parts il ya dix quinze
ans il y aurait eu un passage dans le
bêtisier et c'est tout dans le bêtisier
de noël s'était fait défoncer y avait
pas les réseaux sociaux mais c'était
pour nom d'elias parce que c'est quand
même une énorme bourde ayant poussé les
postes qu'elles causent entre 1.8 en se
foutant de la gueule de sa bourde mais
c'est pas drôle à la limite ce qu'elle
attendait les mouvements passe à autre
chose oui mais attend d'étudier oui elle
se fait défoncer sur les réseaux sociaux
mais quand tu dis une pauvre phrase sur
elle tu t'en tu t'en prends tout autant
planète moi je pense que là ce que j'ai
ce que j'ai dit je vais manger je vais
manger graves sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que de toute façon tu ne peux
jamais rien dire quand il côtoie qu'il
s'agit de gens comme ça qui ont beaucoup
d'influencé sur les réseaux sociaux et
ben non je suis désolé
elle a prouvé que non seulement elle
était diva et qu'en plus elle préparée
pas les émissions dans lesquelles elle
allait et je suis désolé c'est honteux
enfin les divas comme douala les cheveux
teints comme de méthane europa sans
jérémy un petit mot très gentil pour le
coup ya ya ya quelques semaines en
disant surtout aux gens parce que ses
lecteurs ce pire c'est pas ta mosquée le
dire je dis moi c'est les gens qui
derrière partent avec du racisme de
l'homophobie c'est ça qui est au rsa par
les fans de chacun donc j'ai mis un
petit peu un petit mot pour calmer tout
ça voilà je pense effectivement qu'elle
était maladroite moi je redis ce que je
redis c'est déjà j'aimerais beaucoup la
rencontre et je pense que n'en a rien à
[ __ ] de moi elle à l ai dit va aller
tout ça et tout ça on est tous en
revanche oui elle a un talent incroyable
cette jeune fille à la
j'espère qu'un jour un jour tout ça
c'est de la télé
elle viendra on en parlera et c'est vrai
qu'à l'accueil est aussi que 24 ans et
que le succès est venu tellement vite
que c'est pas facile
elle a été très maladroite et c'est vrai
que bon bah voilà du coup je défends
j'aime pas trop khoroto quand tout d'un
coup tout part sur tout le monde est là
maintenant et des russes de blé elle
manque d'originalité dans ce petit
défaut d'agir leurs idées pour durer ça
viendra peut-être poursuivre la 24e
c'était generosa quatre missiles et
toujours pas 55
je plaisante alors